pienso que si en algo nos podemos poner
de acuerdo todas y todos los que nos
encontramos hoy aquí es en la idea que
el mundo está entrando de lleno a una
nueva etapa
al principio de la pandemia y casi como
si pareciera una profecía el filósofo
esloveno slavoj zizek dijo que el
coronavirus
dijo que el coronavirus constituía un
golpe mortal para el capitalismo
la verdad es que el anuncio no es nuevo
antes de él y antes de la pandemia ya
había corrientes filosóficas que
hablaban del fin de la modernidad del
fin de las ideologías ya está del fin de
la historia
estoy segura que en los años que vienen
por delante los y las historiadoras
filósofas y sociólogas hablarán del 2020
como un punto de inflexión en la
historia de la humanidad
a partir del cual los hábitos cotidianos
las formas de producción y hasta las
relaciones humanas habrán tomado una
forma completamente distinta a la que
creíamos conocer
el 2020 y los años que dure la pandemia
marcarán un antes y un después en la
historia de la humanidad como lo fue en
1492 el descubrimiento de américa o en
1789 la revolución francesa
el mundo está tomando una nueva
dirección no sabemos hacia dónde va pero
lo que sí sabemos es cuál es uno de los
grandes agentes de ese cambio
la inclusión de las mujeres
el impacto social que tiene la inclusión
de las mujeres es tan grande y tan
importante como la inclusión de china en
el sistema económico mundial
miren quiero que observen esta gráfica
la economía china hoy vale mil veces más
de lo que valía en el año 2000
casi o más bien poco más de 14 billones
de dólares es lo que aporta china al
sistema económico mundial gracias a su
inclusión en el sistema que conocemos
como libre mercado
saben ustedes qué pasaría
si en el mundo entero las mujeres
ganáramos lo mismo que los hombres
pues hay un estudio publicado por
mckinsey global institute el poder de la
paridad que dice que la economía del
mundo crecería 12 billones de dólares
o sea prácticamente lo mismo que aporta
china al producto bruto global
de este tamaño es el poder transformador
de las mujeres
ahora quiero que vean esta otra gráfica
representa la proporción de hombres y
mujeres inscritos en universidades en
todo el mundo
en 1970 por cada 100 hombres había 73
mujeres
después de 30 años en el ciclo escolar
2001-2002 por fin se registraron el
mismo número de mujeres que de hombres y
desde entonces no hemos cedido terreno
de hecho hoy las mujeres representamos
1.1 veces más que los hombres
con todos estos datos no quiero que ni
por un momento dejemos de mirar todo lo
que está mal
solo quiero que pensemos en los efectos
de esta realidad
la inclusión de las mujeres está siendo
la locomotora que nos está llevando de
lleno a una nueva etapa
y los poderes de esta inclusión ya los
hemos vivido antes quiero que viajen
conmigo al pasado
y recuerden como nos han dicho cómo nos
han platicado que era el mundo antes de
las universidades
un mundo donde el conocimiento era un
privilegio exclusivo de los monarcas y
de los jerarcas religiosos
hace 700 años en los siglos 13 y 14
comenzó la emancipación de las
universidades en europa y en todo el
mundo y de pronto un loco bueno de hecho
varios de ellos decidieron que el
conocimiento debía ser compartido y
cultivado para que rindieran mejores
frutos
y así un centenar de jóvenes
todos hombres por cierto ingresaron a la
universidad
y comenzaron a hacerse preguntas
distintas a las que se hacían los
monarcas
comenzaron a encontrar explicaciones más
allá de la fe y de la tradición
las respuestas que encontraron estos
jóvenes
bueno las respuestas que encontraron
estos jóvenes cambiaron para siempre la
historia de la humanidad
pongamos como ejemplo a guttenberg
a qué monarca oa qué sacerdote se le
hubiera ocurrido que era una mejor idea
imprimir masivamente mapas y libros en
lugar de poner a un séquito de
monaguillos a copiar la biblia
a ninguno
ellos siempre tuvieron acceso al
conocimiento
solo alguien que no tuvo el privilegio
de la educación solo alguien a quien le
hizo falta los libros pudo pensar en la
idea de imprimirlos
pero la historia no para ahí
gracias a la imprenta que inventó
guttenberg llegó a las manos de
cristóbal colón' un libro de un tal
toscanelli que lo inspiró en su idea
loca de viajar a las indias orientales
en sentido contrario y este hombre
convencido de su aventura fue y presentó
su proyecto a la reina isabel que como
buena mujer en el poder
supo tomar una gran decisión y financió
el descubrimiento de américa
que sería del mundo hoy sí gutember no
hubiera ido a la universidad
o que sería de la medicina moderna
y marie curie no hubiera tenido acceso
al conocimiento
sí margaret hamilton la mujer que
inventó la tecnología que nos permitió
pisar la luna no hubiera sido admitida
por el lema
o bueno en tiempos más recientes si
kamala harris no hubiera sido admitida
por la universidad de california
por eso la lucha de málaga por el acceso
de todas las niñas y los niños del mundo
a la educación es fundamental para el
futuro del planeta
de este tamaño es el poder de la
inclusión y de este tamaño está siendo
el efecto de la llegada de cientos de
miles de mujeres a las universidades en
los últimos 50 años en todo el mundo
los frutos de esto ya los estamos
viviendo
en el 2020 al principio de la pandemia
32 países estaban siendo gobernados por
una mujer
y sus resultados en el combate a la
pandemia son impresionantes
los siete países que mejor han manejado
la crisis sanitaria fueron o son
liderados por una mujer
alemania dinamarca islandia finlandia
noruega taiwán y nueva zelanda
jacint a armen primera ministra de nueva
zelanda merece una especial mención a su
país fue el primero en eliminar por
completo y durante varias semanas el
virus de todo su territorio
me encanta su lema me parece que
describe perfecto el estilo de liderazgo
de las mujeres en el poder
visión rica en ser fuerte sé amable
la idea de que el mundo puede ser
gobernado o co gobernado por las mujeres
no sólo se está normalizando sino que
hoy tiene gran aceptación gracias a los
resultados de estas mujeres que nos han
abierto camino
yo he vivido en carne propia el poder de
la inclusión
porque al igual que muchas y muchos de
ustedes tuve la oportunidad de estudiar
una carrera universitaria
y cuando ingresé a la facultad de
derecho de la universidad autónoma de
querétaro encontré mi pasión mi vocación
que es el servicio público y desde esta
oportunidad he podido forjar me una
carrera de 12 años ininterrumpidos de
servicio a mi comunidad
yo he visto y he vivido el poder de la
inclusión gracias a acciones afirmativas
que impulsaron mujeres que lucharon
antes de mí
porque de hecho recuerdo muy bien que al
inicio de mi carrera pues yo era la
única mujer en un grupo de jóvenes
políticos y eso hoy ya cambio
segundo porque en estos 12 años he
podido hacer sonar mi voz para integrar
en una agenda social los problemas que
veo y que vivo todos los días en la
calle y con especial fuerza he podido
representar los derechos de más de la
mitad de la población de este país
gracias a la inclusión
las mujeres hoy tenemos una voz que se
escucha y que complementa una gente
integral
porque simple y sencillamente vivimos
realidades muy distintas unos que otros
porque a que hombre por más simpático
que sea las causas de género
se le hubiera ocurrido luchar por
combatir la violencia obstétrica que
sufren miles de mujeres embarazadas en
mexico en pleno siglo 21
o sin incluir la voz de las mujeres a
cuantos les hubiera parecido importante
crear un registro nacional de deudores
de pensiones alimenticias
y que proteja el derecho de las mujeres
pero que garantice un mejor futuro para
las niñas y para los niños de méxico
de ese tamaño es el poder de la
inclusión
si no hubiera mujeres en el congreso
todas estas iniciativas no habían sido
presentadas discutidas y muchísimo menos
aprobadas
y así les puedo citar cientos de
ejemplos de los jóvenes de las
comunidades indígenas de los derechos de
las personas con discapacidad de
cualquier grupo que tenga una menor
representación
la inclusión nos abre los ojos y amplía
nuestros horizontes
la inclusión enriquece nuestras
diferencias y las convierte en
oportunidades de desarrollo
pero saben que es lo mejor de la
inclusión
que es para todas y para todos
no es una agenda que beneficia
exclusivamente a las mujeres
esto es muy importante
quiero decirles que
aunque he podido hacer sonar mi voz en
espacios en recintos en foros muy
importantes
el poder estar aquí hoy haciendo esta
plática con ustedes es realmente muy
importante para mí estoy muy emocionada
me compromete me siento entusiasmada
porque hoy puedo decirte a ti mujer que
has roto la barrera de la exclusión
desde tu espacio como estudiante como
jefa como directora como emprendedora
como mamá que hoy podemos abrir camino a
otras mujeres
y construir una sociedad en la que
hombres y mujeres nos complementemos
tenemos tres grandes herramientas para
continuar promoviendo la inclusión para
luchar por la inclusión
lo vamos a hacer con nuestra voz lo
vamos a hacer con nuestras manos pero
sobre todo lo vamos a hacer con nuestro
corazón
con nuestra voz vamos a seguir
sensibilizando a la sociedad
porque es vital señalar la desigualdad
la exclusión y todas las injusticias que
se siguen cometiendo en nuestra contra
porque es urgente dejar de normalizar
todo tipo de violencia porque no es
normal que ganemos menos que los hombres
porque es ridículo que se piense que una
mujer que trabaja en el hogar no trabaja
y porque es indignante que todos los
días desaparezcan 11 mujeres en méjico
por el hecho de ser mujeres
alcemos la voz porque hoy todavía hay
muchas personas que no se dan cuenta de
esto alcemos la voz para provocar la
indignación de hombres y mujeres que es
el look que se sumen a la lucha de la
inclusión
segundo lo vamos a hacer con nuestras
manos porque en cada mujer en alguna
condición de privilegio como somos todas
las que estamos hoy aquí
está la semilla del cambio que queremos
ver en el mundo como decía gandhi
hoy hombres y mujeres conscientes del
problema podemos convertirnos en
vigilantes cotidianos de la igualdad
sustantiva
una directora de recursos humanos tiene
que ser quien vigile que las mujeres
ganen igual un director o una directora
de una escuela debe ser especialmente
sensible ante el acoso escolar una
presidenta debe garantizar que las leyes
se cumplan con perspectiva de género y
así todo fluye y todos sumamos en la
lucha de la inclusión
tercero lo vamos a hacer con nuestro
corazón mujeres inspirando mujeres
mujeres creyendo en mujeres mujeres
apoyando mujeres mujeres incluyendo
también a los hombres hoy aquí en esta
sala podría estar entre nosotras la
primera presidenta de mexico la primera
rectora de la universidad anáhuac
querétaro
la primera mujer mexicana en pisar la
luna
o la inventora de la vacuna en contra de
todas las enfermedades conocidas o la
ingeniera que salvará el planeta de
todas las industrias contaminantes esa
persona podría ser cualquiera de ustedes
con nuestra voz con nuestras manos y con
nuestro corazón tenemos el poder de
decidir cómo será el futuro de la
humanidad y ese futuro es la inclusión
para mí la inclusión
significa la oportunidad de sumar
distintos puntos de vista de distintas
personas que se enfrentan a realidades
muy diferentes todos los días en la
construcción de una mejor versión de
nosotros como sociedad
hagamos de la inclusión nuestra forma de
vivir muchas gracias
[Aplausos]